too i remember went on a date with a  girl once and she was like you've never  tried ayahuasca and i was like i'm a  neurotic jew like what do you think  i don't do well with weed you think  ayahuasca is the the logical next thing  right hey right i'm gonna go to  nicaragua and try this plant with a  shaman what are you kidding well they're  like like i cried for hours i i found  out stuff that would have taken me years  in therapy i was like i'll take the  years in therapy yeah i'll work up to it  maybe you cried for hours because you  weren't ready for all this [ __ ] yeah  crying for hours isn't a good selling  point  my uncle yeah  you gotta get molested you cry for hours  you see a few things you never felt  before it's the same [ __ ]  the only difference is there are no  retreats  yeah yeah we're going he  but either way he shows up in a robe  [Applause]  yeah you can either go to south america  or the shed